هذه
[موسيقى]
على سبيل المثال ، اسمي Büşra و Lütfi Manisa محطة القطار.
وتركيا
العمرة هي شركة والدك وزر الجزية.
اسطنبول كلغة إنجليزية أدبية
Enes letter a أنقرة
أيس وأنقرة
أنا آية iluga
إلى الانجليزية
فيدات للسيارة
Vecettü Baldur Kutub الأمومة إنها تنتمي إلى But
لا تؤذي نفسك يا محمود
و vegettu
شراء الاشياء فديل فيجانة الجزيرة هذا
حدثني عن العربية مع منطقته
مفيد جدا شخص يعمل في وسائل الإعلام
إضافة ضخمة باللغة العربية
لأن
جغرافيتنا قريبة جدا من بعضها البعض.
علاقاتنا منفصلة
بينما يتابع الإعلام العربي الذي لا يمكن تصوره
deezire هو مصدر رئيسي صريح
لأنه قال فقط هذا وذاك كسياسة.
لا يقول ما قاله من الجمهور من الشارع
أحد الشعراء يتحدث مع الناس
إبراز ووصف الرسامين
لذلك عند فهم حدث ما ، فقط سياسي
أنت لا تنظر إليه بالكامل
ماذا قال عنها الناس في الشارع
ما حدث في الماضي
الجزيرة تختتم بشكل جيد جدا يا
هو يعرف
مثل المال أثناء مطاردة الملكة
وكأنه يتنزه في الشوارع
أنا أشعر
[موسيقى]
اشترك